it's a lot to be like talking at the
same time it's a little much I just take
him with the almond okay what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today I'm joined by
Natalie Portman she's an Oscar
award-winning actress who's been in the
game since before she was a teenager
you know from iconic roles in films like
Jackie and Black Swan just to name a few
and her latest project is the
documentary about the state of factory
farming in America it's called eating
animals and hits theaters June 15th
Natalie welcome to the show thank you so
we're going vegan wings today obviously
just as we have with Russell Brand Ricky
Gervais and others but for better or
worse the sauces are still very much the
same how are you a spicy food I like
spicy food I don't want to talk up my
skill too much before don't worry but I
do like spice so I'm excited about this
[Music]
I'm Scott
[Music]
a lot of June the vegan wings are a
little bit spongy err sometimes so wanna
start by acknowledging the elephant in
the room because through watching the
film it really made me reconsider the
future of this show but that's an
existential crisis for another time I am
wondering though when you first read the
book what are some of the stats the
anecdotes the facts that really stood
out to you and inspired now the new
project eating animals well I think that
um I didn't realize that most of our
meat dairy eggs are from factory farms
that it's not just like oh art of it and
everything else is nice funds it's the
vast majority and and when you see what
it does to the environment like they're
spraying like the pig [ __ ] up in the air
and it's giving people all these
respiratory diseases who live near pig
farms so the human impact the
environmental impact and you just see
that that it's having a huge toll beyond
even the animal suffering which is
something that is also super disturbing
and that's what's interesting about it
because the film tries to reframe the
debate over the ethics of eating animals
away from hashtag eat clean and how
could you eat that cute baby cow to the
broader consequences of factory farming
and besides see the damn movie I am
curious what is your barroom pitch for
not eating animals I say to people like
I think it's really hard to completely
change but if everyone cut out meat
dairy eggs from one of their meals a day
or one day a week like if you could
commit to that for yourself if everyone
do that it would make such a huge impact
environmentally and on how many animals
are put into difficult conditions and
then I know that you've given a
commencement speech at Harvard you've
won an Oscar but I am curious where does
nabbing PETA's Sexiest Vegetarian honor
rank in your list of professional
accomplishment very very high very high
yes there's a lot of sexy vegetarians Oh
and you have the crown Natalie ready to
move on yes all right so this next one
is the heartbeat hot sauce good so some
of your fans might not realize that your
love for rap music doesn't start and end
with these iconic SNL digital shorts
Andy Samberg said that you proved your
commitment to the project by spending a
little Kim verse do you remember which
song you chose probably the jump off I
listen to that a lot in that era what's
your favorite Natalie's rap bar when you
look back on the two videos well now of
course I like I got mommy moves that's
when I can use in my life as I'm like
packing school lunch
she's got mommy moves I got mommy moves
delicious people don't understand the
logistical complications of an interview
Food Show you know it's true you got
stuff in your teeth there's a lot that
can go wrong yeah you'd tell me though
right I got you okay I got you
Thanks so you're someone whose resume
reflects an insane degree of self
discipline and focus but I know that you
have a weakness Natalie can you describe
your food show Mount Rushmore your top
four yes
Fujio Mount Rushmore is Top Chef master
chef junior iron chef and chopped I like
cooking and I like competition that's
like the the Nexus that really satisfies
me that's the intersection for you and
you know Padma and Tom have both taken
on the wings of death what surprised you
when you're a guest chef on Top Chef it
surprised me how long you tape that it's
like a full-day thing like you start in
the morning and you're really just
eating all day I was really impressed
with how much they could eat because
after one day I was like oh man and I
eat like large quantities I just try and
take a bite of everything and then move
the stuff on the plate so I don't hurt
anyone's feelings
so it's not every day we have someone
with a psychology degree in the hot seat
not only that but someone who's
co-authored scientific papers such as
frontal lobe activation during object
permanence so with that in mind I want
to hit you with a handful of highly
debated questions of the mind does
having a psychology background give you
any sort of edge in Hollywood it's the
same thing really being an actor and the
study of psychology because you're
basically looking at people and thinking
why they do the things they do do dreams
matter are they significant at all I
don't think so no I think they're like
your brain just getting rid of
information it doesn't need and then
your brain naturally puts it into
stories that's what I think of it what's
your take on the psychological toll of
social media is there real danger to
obsessively scrolling Instagram yes
there's a lot of like um self obsession
I think does eating a taco from the top
rather than from the side make me a
psychopath no it's just annoying alright
so this next one is Lowe's calientes
you're not just saying that hmm you
don't have to know it's good right
Natalie were a recurring segment on our
show called explain that Graham we do a
deep dive and I guess Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context we don't deep into the Gettys
for natalie portman so what I'll do is
I'll just bust out the laptop I'll show
you the picture and then you just tell
me the bigger stories that sound good
sounds good
all right laptop please all right
is it true that when you were at Harvard
you brought some guy friends over to
Britney Spears's birthday we actually
co-hosted a New Year's party Wow
yes it was really fun we danced a lot
that night
speaking of dancing what do you remember
about learning to crank that was soldier
boy these are this is a good deep dive
little I have like clearly amnesia about
my own life no idea I'm gonna remember
that day yes yes I remember the steps I
do not do you you know them I do you do
like a like you know Superman that oh
right was that unlike TRL or something
[Laughter]
[Music]
good so I wanna stay on the topic of
getting jiggy with it cuz as we know
Natalie Portman's love for dance it
doesn't end on the TRL set No what's
your record for consecutive pirouettes
not many I'm not very good at pirouettes
I can do maybe two since Black Swan
there's been a couple moments of ballet
bubbling up in pop culture when you
think about Missy Copeland's Under
Armour commercial or Kanye West's
runaway video and I'm wondering does
that make ballet more accessible more
relevant to a younger audience or just
one of those things that annoys the
purists no I think it's great the more
ballet gets exposed to larger audiences
I mean there are great artists athletes
and what these professional dancers can
do is so incredible and should be part
of pop culture
does it ever get hot for you this is
like your concept right right for us we
were just like you know how do we
subvert the celebrity interview you know
and to our solve for that was hot sauce
but I'm no like hot sauce hero okay come
one you know so I still suffer for like
you know it's finger love
yeah for sure okay this is the bun stirs
the bun stirs black label out of
Australia like it's a 16 out of 10 that
want to hit like at the back of my
throat mmm-hmm but oh good I'll just
gonna have some almond milk there's no
shame in that it's good though
so when aaron sorkin was writing the
social network is biopic about Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg I know that you
got some Harvard buddies together to
dish on campus life dirt do you remember
some of the inside baseball you fed him
um I think just mainly talked about what
the finals club scene was like rather
than like frats there were finals clubs
which are kind of like fancy
fraternities boys clubs and I'm getting
I'm getting the heat now and yeah you
could only get in if the guys let you in
and you know it was a it was a funny
scene can I give you three things that
I'm told are extremely Harvard and then
if you'd be kind enough to explain it as
much of detail as possible and
appreciate it okay the freshman 15 list
primal scream finals clubs so Freshman
Fifteen list was the hottest freshmen
you don't say freshman's you say
freshmen that's the that's the spice
talk I'm just gonna flame everything
stupid I say on the spice primal scream
is when the they do like a race around
the yard where everyone's naked and they
brought naked I my freshman year some
kids like put water down that froze so
that they all slightly which is awful
all these kids like piled up on top of
each other and then and then yeah the
finals clubs are like they're like fancy
fraternities we all hung out
[Music]
it's getting really serious now
beyond insanity okay on top of it
it's okay very impressive Thanks
I mean it's spicy good I'm just trying
to read your eyes on that it's hot
you're not having any milk yeah if
you're gonna invite it I'm gonna go I
mean
I cleared my sinuses yeah as we've
touched on your on Natalie's rap SNL
skits you respond to cliche interview
questions with these very violent rap
tirades as somebody who's been in this
business since before you were a
teenager I know it's all jokes but I'm
sure that that was cathartic on some
level yeah how if at all does the
International Press differ from the
American press in certain countries you
definitely get specific things that you
don't get in other places I feel like I
get some more political questions in
Europe in Asia they'll ask about
specific like Asian things like if I
know about their particular films or
caffeic culture or things like that is
there a country that does entertainment
media better than other countries Japan
definitely has a fun time you've done a
lot of fully crying right now there's a
little bit of glisten in your eyes but I
would say I know I know
oh why you're so composed I really I
mean okay I like it it's a lot to be
like talking at the same time it's a
little much
just to came at the oven not okay but
you've also done a lot of off-piste
things like between two ferns and of
course this freak show do you see a
change in the ways that celebrity is
handled in the media over the last
couple of years well it's nice that
interviews are kind of like trying to be
more fun now cuz I feel like no one
wants to just hear a boring question
answers about your movie is sitting in a
chair so this is more entertaining
hopefully how about for you though
painful this one's called Hellfire
what's going down
[Laughter]
so how long does it take for your math
to feel like normal after so we still
have one more sauce to go so I'm not
gonna make any promises about when the
roller-coaster will start to go back
down again I'm not sweating and crying
and snotting and mouth as I clean but
you are on top of it Natalie I would say
that you know we have people come in
here they do laps around the studio yeah
they're just pouring milk over their
heads and everything so it's like you
actually are very composed even though
on the inside it might be no I mean it's
it's manageable but respect salute
what makes Lily Tomlin and Diane Keaton
your comedic heroes have such unique
voices and personalities and I think
there's so many like stereotypes of how
we want to see women and how we want
women to behave in society that you know
we're not just see we're just not seeing
enough like different personalities and
different types of people cuz there's a
whole spectrum you know not just girls
wanting to get married and talk about
boys with each other and then I know
that you don't partake anymore but you
are a fan of the stoner film genre what
do you think is the greatest stoner film
of all time Lebowski all right Natalie
Portman it's it's a shame that you know
in sort of alcohol you know as an
accompaniment but you know what you just
put that in the rider oh yeah we had
Johnny Knoxville in here last week use
this crushin you know you just put that
in the email and we got you I see the
seeds you're added
[Music]
this is the last DAP Redux we call it
the last dab because it's tradition
around here to put a little extra on the
last wing you don't have to if you don't
want to I don't say no to dares there it
is
there it is Natalie Portman Dabin wings
slightly aggressive but we dig our own
graves on this show
bottoms up that one's unpleasant but
thanks for introducing me to this okay I
don't know maybe finish my milk
there you go chug chug chug all right
Natalie Portman here we are at the end
of the road having conquered some of the
hottest vegan chicken wings in the
history of Earth and now there's just
one more hurdle to jump in 2015 you gave
a commencement speech to the graduating
class at Harvard and now that you have a
trillion scovilles lighting your brain
on fire
I'm curious what PostScript would you
add in the age of russian hacking Logan
Paul and teenagers eating Tide Pods
that's a big question
I'd say hmm
pay attention to the news vote and make
sure your vote is real make sure it's a
real democracy and we're not being
controlled by outside forces well you
heard it here first
Natalie Portman crankin speech
PostScript tears down her face I don't
know if it came from the hot sauce if
she's just proud of herself for
finishing
but either way a pat on the back and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you Natalie Portman
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
eating animals is coming out very soon
in big cities across the country and you
should see it because it will teach you
why you should eat vegan chicken wings
with your hot sauce and not support
factory farming let's concludes the hot
ones experience how you feeling on fire
yeah what long seriously does it take oh
yeah yeah yeah it's it has a half-life
you know what I mean so as bad as you're
feeling now is the worst that you're
gonna feel little milk
something chill it's not it was very
delicious water makes worse really yeah
Aloha spice Lords if you're wondering
why I'm sitting on this beautiful beach
it's because I'm celebrating
Loes calientes the sauce of summer in
the newest addition to the hot ones hot
sauce family this is Beach vibes in a
bottle sweet smoky spicy and I might be
biased but I think it's the best hot
sauce we've ever made and here's the
exciting news if you want to pick up a
bottle it's available now you know the
drill heat nice calm heat nice calm for
your bottle of lows calientes louis
calientes muy delicioso
you
[Music]